The Joe Rogan Experience this movie was
gonna sit on the [__] shelf Joe
you've done so much for me do it for Joe
guys do it for Joe do it for me prove
that he's the [__] well I just
think it's a funny [__] movie man
it's a good movie it's actually gonna be
fun it's a big action comedy that needs
to be seen on the big screen and and I I
and and I think it's I think people will
be surprised at how fun this movie is
it's it's just [__]
fun and I'm I've been [__] up promo I
was telling you I've been [__] up
promotion for it because I'm way too
honest I'm not an actor like I'm just
like they're like what are the kissing
scenes like and I'm like
rough
[Laughter]
we have one kissing scene
I didn't know I didn't know there was
kissing scenes in the movies I don't
read the action when I read the scripts
I just read the dialogue
so I don't read like you know hey uh
Bert comes back kisses his wife and
knocks her off her feet I just go like
oh there Leanne was in Serbia and they
were like hey you have a kissing scene
today I was like what and they're like
yeah your wife and I was like shut the
[__] up
I was like is that cool and Leann's like
yes you're an actor I was like yeah but
I haven't cheated on you and like I ever
like I've kissed someone 20 [__]
years she was like it's just acting and
I was like okay
all I'll say is uh the pants I was
wearing were loose fitting and I don't
wear underwear
we did one take and I was like costume
change please
they're like what I was like I need to
change my pants I guess I'm not an actor
I'm just a regular dude
oh my goodness bro
they're like they're like huh and I was
like I don't know what the [__] you
supposed to do you supposed to kiss
someone and then just like how the [__]
does that work
you ever kiss someone your body doesn't
know that it's just acting no no no no
how could it yeah
I did the first kiss my my wife
Stephanie is cool as [__] by the way
I've talked with her and we've talked
about this a number of times
and she goes
if you do the first kiss and I'm and I'm
like I don't know I'm I'm just like you
know and she's like hey you know really
go for it like really go for it I was
like for real she said yeah like try
like try to like knock me off my feet
like Kiss Me so I was like okay
I'm not thinking about it
walk up boom and as soon as and then she
kissed back and I was like what the [__]
is happening this is different holy [__]
and then I'm like costume change
I need tape I need tape hey someone give
me ice
is that are you allowed to talk about
that you're not supposed to you're
supposed to say like you're supposed to
say here ask me what the kissing scene
was like what was the kissing scene like
you know it was good it was it's just
acting it's just acting it's what we do
as actors
okay which is true yeah well it is for
some people but it's also a [__]
hardcore lie it's also why Brad Pitt
[__] Angelina Jolie it's because you
make out with her a couple times you're
like that was [__] nice I wonder what
it's like and then you're laying in bed
going
and Jennifer Anderson's texting you like
pass pass like [__] Leanne we did the
kissing scene all day all day I kissed
this woman for like 30 minutes 35
minutes kissed her like got comfortable
kissing her and then we got in bed in
Serbia and Leanne's like hey you wanna I
was like Beat It scissor lips it's like
I'm [__] I'll come back to you when I
need to
oh wow rude
my wife's got a good sense of humor I
hope so yeah I had the whole [__] I
mean the whole movie in general was like
I was not coming I ripped my [__] arm
I blew my arm out but what is it like to
have a story get turned into a movie
that's got to be weird as [__]
uh like a story that like you kind of
have to tell now
like if you do a show if you do a show
and you don't tell the machine story
people will get angry but they did it
last time I was here yeah we were up
here and they started chanting the
machines and I was like guys I'm at the
comedy Mothership I'm just in an hour 15
and that was the best that was one of
the cool that's the coolest thing about
that goddamn Club is I see [__] Ron
up in the top and I go I'll tell I'll
tell the machine if Ron comes down and
tells tater salad and the place is like
Ron White's here and then and Ron's like
[__] it I'm coming down Ron White comes
on stage tells tater salad I go to tell
the machine and realize I can't follow
tater salad
the best story ever told so
it's surreal having your movie your life
turn into movie it's surreal like it is
like it was emotional at times and then
it's and then it's weird because you you
feel I feel very vulnerable you know
like because some of the questions
people ask they're like uh they're not
they don't they like they take they put
teeth in it they're like so you rob
people and you're like Jesus Christ see
you you approve of what the mafia does
you're like into the mafia and I'm like
hey man could not make us a real like
you're keeping your eyes open while we
kiss let's [__] just make it regular
a Good Morning America
so they got upset with the premise
they were just like they like they they
read half of it and then they're like so
you you're in the mafia and you're like
no it's a little more complex but no but
you like got welcomed into the mafia and
you're like
yeah like that kind of it's better when
you hear the whole story I think I tell
it a little different they're like and
you robbed your friends are they cool
with you now and I'm like yeah yeah some
of them are coming to the premiere like
[__] Jesus Christ let's can we move
to the next subject I don't believe in
vaccines
[Laughter]
oh my God
yeah it's been it's been interesting
it's been fun I'll tell you what's been
really fun is finding out just how
why this story has reached like I didn't
expect certain people to be like fans of
mine like and I I know that sounds like
bad but like
you're always like when you look at your
audiences they my audience kind of looks
like the same one thing guys that have
chicks that are hotter than they deserve
they all have beards they're all a
little overweight like that's my fan
base
I I like I I literally go hey man I can
tell you the sponsors I can get for my
tour Lipitor would be a good sponsor
some blood pressure medicine some beard
trimmers not Lipitor I know we're
talking about statins but
um but like I know like I know my fan
base and then you get like dudes who are
like I [__] love you and like like
big boy from Big Boys neighborhood I was
like you know who I am he was like yeah
why wouldn't I I was like I don't know I
just didn't think you know like Nori
from dream Champs he's like dude I'm the
he goes I told my wife we you get we got
my favorite comedian coming on and she's
like you mean the big fat white guy with
the takes his shirt off and you're like
wait when you're younger you try so hard
to appeal to all demographics almost
like you want it's like fake and then
once you're yourself
you're truly yourself that's when you
appeal that's when you're the most
appealing does that make sense it does
make sense yeah because it's hard to do
it's hard to do publicly yeah it's hard
to be you know yourself publicly
especially when you're promoting a movie
about yourself to be yourself publicly
you start understanding like Joaquin
Phoenix oh my God for sure you start
going like yeah I don't wanna like
like
secret time uh I suppose this will Air
this will it'll be fine the premieres
tomorrow I'm flying back tonight for the
premiere the premier list is [__]
thick it's [__] thick
it's kind of [__] it's like it's my
algorithm it's Snoop Dogg porn stars and
[__] radio DJs
couple Pro Surfers like it's my
algorithm my watch dealer the
um but uh
like Mark Hamill was like are you gonna
stay for the and watch the movie and I
was like are we not supposed to he's
like I'm not gonna watch myself on
screen and I was like why and he's like
oh are you being serious he's like you
want to just you're gonna sit in front
of 750 people and watch yourself
and I was like I was like hey Mark
secret time I'm gonna cry watching
myself I'm gonna cry and I'm gonna mouth
my my lines I did that when we did the
first testing of the movie they sat me
in the front row I had two bottles of
wine I sat with Leanne I had a notebook
I was supposed to write things in for
notes the movie starts and I start
bawling crying I start bawling crying
and I start mouthing my lines I'm
laughing hysterically I'm like I love I
loved watching me more than a narcissist
whatever like it was like the craziest
thing so we go to the next screening and
uh kale our producer pulls me aside he
goes I'm gonna ask you to sit in the
back
I said what he goes it kind of affect
the way people watch the movie so what
do you mean he goes I don't know if
they're [__] crying like it's Cape
Fear but gay he goes [__] sit in the
back so the next time I sat in the back
but I get emotional watching the movie
because I feel like
I feel like I'm watching a highlight
reel like I remember doing all these
things and now they're all cut cool and
so I was like I don't know I guess um I
don't know I think I'll watch the movie
I guess I would